[تصفيق]
مواجهه على العشب الاخضر اشعلت حربا
تاريخيا بين دولتين خارج الملعب راح ضيتها
الاف القتلى والجرحى هذا ما حدث اثناء
التصفيات المؤهله لكاس العالم عام 1970
عقب مباراه جمعت منتخبي السلفادور
وهندوراس في المكسيك عام
1969 بعد ما انتهت مباراه الذهاب والاياب
بفوز كل منهما في ملعبه لكن ما السبب وراء
هذه الحرب التي اطلق عليها اسم حرب الكره
السلفادور دوله مساحه صغيره وكانت اغلب
اراضيها الزراعيه تتحكم فيها نخبه قليله
من الاقطاعين لذا هاجر الكثير من
المزارعين السلفادوريين الفقراء الى
هندوراس التي تبلغ مساحتها خمسه اضعاف
مساحه السلفادور والمعروفه باراضها الخصبه
لكن هذه الهجره تسببت بنزاع جنسيه
بلدين لاحقا
الاقطاعين بالسيلفادور كانوا يدعمون
الهجره التي تخفف الضغط على اراضيهم ولكن
الامر ادى الامتعاض المزارعين في الهنتراس
الذين كانوا يناضلون للحصول على مزيد من
الاراضي
وقتها او حتى حاكمها في وجود نحو 300 الف
مزارع سلفادوري على اراضي بلادهم لذا قرر
الرئيس حينها اسوالتا لوبيز اريلاندو
البدء بترحيل سيلفا دوريين
[موسيقى]
الصحافه في تلك الفتره مارست دورا من شانه
اثاره الراي العام السلفادوري فقد تحدثت
عن اضطهاد المزارعين السلفادور في هندوراس
وزععمت ان حالات اغتصاب وقتل وقعت بحق
العشرات هناك هذه المشاعر وموجات الغضب
والاحداث السياسيه كانت قبل المباراه
وحولتها من مجرد مباراه في كره القدم الى
مواجهه ثاريه
لقد شعرنا وقتها ان علينا واجبا وطنيا هو
الفوز من اجل سلفرادور كنا نخشى الخساره
بسبب تلك الظروف كانت الخساره تعني عار
الابديا لكن ما لم ندركه ان ذلك الفوز
وذلك الهدف سيكون رمزا للحرب
السلفادور تنتصر في حرب كره القدم هكذا
عنوانه وكاله الانباء الامريكيه يوبي اي
في اليوم التالي للمباراه التي فازت بها
السيلفادور بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدفين
لقد هتف المشجعون سيلفادوريون في المدرجات
قاتله قتله
ايام قليله واندلعت الحرب مناوشات حدوديه
بين البلدين على اثرها امرت حكومه
السلفادور قواتها في الرابعه عشر من يوليو
عام
1969 بغزو هندوراس وشنغارات جويه ضدها
طبول الحرب قرعه اربعه ايام من القتال
المستمر بين البلدين لذا سميت حرب المئه
ساعه قتال الدلوقوع ثلاثه الاف قتيل
اغلبهم من المدنيين في هندوراس وتشريد
مئات الالاف
كانت هذه الحرب واساسا حول الارض هناك
كثير من الناس في مساحه صغيره
تدخلت ونجحت في التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار ثم سحبت السلفادور قواتها تحت الضغط
الدولي ومع ذلك ما زال التوتر مستمر بين
البلدين وما زالت النزاعات الحدوديه
متواصله بينهما حتى هذه الايام